[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros en
france 24 y comenzamos en 5 minutos con
nos acompaña el señor pablorromero
sanchis psicólogo clínico e investigador
general house y university en nueva
escocia canadá para hablar de salud
mental en tiempos de pandemia gracias
por acompañarnos y por esta comunicación
señor romero cual en términos generales
es el efecto de la pandemia en la salud
mental
bueno esto es esta pandemia ha sido una
destrucción enorme para todo el mundo y
nos ha cambiado completamente la vida
nos ha vaciado la vida de esas pequeñas
cosas que formaban nuestro día a día que
nos daban seguridad que nos daban que
nos daban tranquilidad y ahora no
podemos hacer muchas de esas cosas con
lo cual todo eso ha afectado a nuestra
salud mental ha aumentado el nivel de
ansiedad ha aumentado el nivel de
depresión tenemos informes por ejemplo
de la cruz roja que dice que la mitad de
las personas
ambi se han visto afectada su salud
mental e informes que dicen que 32 hay
un 32% de prevalencia de problemas de
ansiedad y 34% de problemas de estado de
ánimo con lo cual ha sido una
destrucción enorme de nuestra salud
mental cuáles son los principales
temores de las personas y cómo
enfrentarlo señor romero donde pedir
ayuda
bueno en nuestro estudio en un estudio
internacional que estamos realizando
lo que estamos viendo es que hay dos
componentes principales por un lado
tenemos la incertidumbre y por otro lado
tenemos la percepción de la amenaza la
percepción de la amenaza que tenemos de
esta situación es muy variada desde
nuestra salud porque nos podemos ver
contagiados por el virus a la pérdida de
trabajo pérdida de poder adquisitivo la
economía no sabemos cómo va a reaccionar
entonces eso es un componente muy
importante y por otro lado tenemos la
incertidumbre no sabemos cómo a ciencia
cierta cómo nos contagiamos del virus
cómo nos podemos cómo podemos estar
protegidos del virus si iba a venir
unidad de grupo si va a haber una cura
si va haber vacuna hay una incertidumbre
enorme y sabemos que la incertidumbre es
algo que provoca grandes problemas de
salud mental no solamente ansiedad sino
problemas de estado de ánimo y otra
variedad de emociones como por ejemplo
rabia culpa ira es un es un conjunto de
emociones que no sabemos manejar
para tenemos que pedir ayuda a nuestros
recursos de salud mental habituales pero
luego también tenemos otros recursos
especiales la página web de la
organización mundial de la salud tiene
varios recursos nosotros en nuestra en
la página web de nuestro estudio que es
kobe y 19a n puntocom estamos colgando
recursos también tanto para personas
como para terapeutas vamos a colgar
entonces tenemos que hacer uso de todos
esos recursos porque esta situación es
excepcional y tenemos que aprender a
manejarla en este escenario totalmente
atípico hay un punto del que poco se
habla y es el de la realización de los
rituales fúnebres que han tenido que ser
solitarios cómo afecta esto a la familia
qué repercusiones puede tener bueno esto
es una de las disrupciones de las que
hablaba y como todos sabemos cuando hay
una perdida cuando hay un fallecimiento
hay un duelo un proceso de duelo que la
mejor manera de pasarlo es en familia
con los seres queridos con los amigos
para tener esa experiencia común que nos
haga procesar esa pérdida de la mejor
manera posible efectivamente esta es una
de las disrupciones que ha provocado el
kobe y tenemos que intentar buscar la
mejor solución posible intentar
s bueno intentar estar con los nuestros
utilizando otro tipo otro tipo de medios
sean medios telemáticos están en
contacto con nuestra gente porque es
imprescindible si no lo hacemos podemos
provocar peores problemas de salud
mental en el futuro hablemos también del
consumo del alcohol de las drogas de la
violencia de género ha sido un riesgo en
materia de salud sin duda sin duda en
muchísimos países en multitud de países
se ha visto un aumento del consumo de
alcohol por ejemplo en canadá sabemos
que se hace y canadá no es uno de los
países más afectados por el cómic pero
sabemos que ha habido un 25 por ciento
de incremento en el consumo de alcohol
por razones tan diferentes como por
ejemplo aburrimiento o estrés pero
sabemos que ese incremento en el consumo
de alcohol ha sido en todo el mundo la
violencia de género
exactamente igual sabemos que han
aumentado en diferentes países como
argentina francia a reino unido en todo
el mundo en el orden del 30 por ciento
de las llamadas a los a los servicios de
emergencia por este tipo de motivos por
violencia de género la responsabilidad
es de los gobiernos y de las autoridades
de poner recursos
esas personas están en un momento de
mucha mucha vulnerabilidad en sus
instantes muy bien pues muchas gracias
para los romeros sanchis por tus
recomendaciones profesionales él es
psicólogo clínico e investigador en
dalhousie university de nueva escocia
canadá y muchas gracias a ustedes por su
compañía ya lo sabe vea más mucho más en
france24 punto com
[Música]